الآن بعض ضحايا
الحرب الإسرائيلية على حماس هي مواقع تاريخية ومعالم لا
تقدر بثمن في كنائس غزة
والمساجد والمؤسسات الثقافية الأخرى،
بعضها موجود منذ
آلاف السنين وقد تحول الآن إلى
غبار، ويظهر لنا ركام بشير ما
فقدوه.  الكنوز الثقافية
ومراكز المجتمع في
غزة أصبحت الآن تحت
الأنقاض مثل تدمر في سوريا أو
مدينة النمرود القديمة في العراق ضحايا
الحرب. تظهر هذه الصور
كنيسة القديس فيريوس، وهي واحدة من أقدم الكنائس في العالم
قبل بدء الهجوم الإسرائيلي قبل 3 أشهر.
هذا ما يبدو عليه الأمر الآن بعد
الغارة الجوية الإسرائيلية في أكتوبر، ما هو
السبب الذي جعلنا نطلب من الله أن يحل
السلام في المنطقة،
جذورنا هنا، نحن هنا منذ 2000 عام
ولن
نعيش، سنبقى  هنا
سنواصل
حياتنا يقول والد الكنيسة حبيب سيلاس
إن 17 شخصًا لقوا حتفهم في الغارة على
المجمع الذي كان الناس يحتمون به.
تقول إسرائيل إنه كان عبارة عن
أضرار جانبية ولم يكن
الهدف المقصود
ولكنه ليس الموقع التاريخي الوحيد الذي
يوجد به  تم
تدمير المسجد الكبير في غزة، وله
تاريخ يقال إنه يعود إلى
زمن الفلسطينيين، وقد أمضى بعض
الوقت كمعبد وكنيسة
قبل أن يصبح مسجدًا اليوم، وكل ما
بقي قائمًا هو
مناجم مكتبته التي تحتوي على
مخطوطات تاريخية إلى حد كبير  لقد فقدوا المسجد
نفسه كما يمكننا القول إنه
رمز للشعب وكرمز
للحياة
الثقافية اليومية في غزة أه لذا أه
للأسف مع هذا فقد الناس
في غزة فقدوا رمزًا مهمًا جدًا
لهويتهم و  لاحظ
أيضًا المدينة، وهي ليست مجرد أماكن
عبادة، فهذا الحمام الذي يُقال إنه تم
بناؤه في القرن الرابع عشر، كان
في أيدي نفس العائلة
لأجيال، وقد تم تدميره في لحظة، حيث
قال الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه كان يستهدف
فرقة إرهابية تابعة لحماس كلما
تنتهي هذه الحرب وتبدأ عملية إعادة الإعمار، هناك
شيء واحد مؤكد أن الكثير من
تاريخ غزة يقع الآن تحت الأنقاض شمال شرق بشير سي إن إن
في
بيروت